we wanted unity to be sort of a restart
of the brand right so we looked at all
the other games we had AC one had these
type of open-ended missions the issue
was always variety was that we didn't
have all the systems to support them to
make this actually varied enough
throughout the experience now that we
have all the city stuff all that come
all those different missions those
pillars those different gameplay blocks
we can do that again but do it right
this time you know ready for next gen
all we saw we'd give you at the
beginning is an objective sort of could
be like kill a target so we give you
that mission the objective we show you
what the playground is so we show you
with a camera like a sort of a
bird's-eye view camera this is your
playground and we give you stats like in
this mission you have for example one
special assassination we have ten secret
entrances or whatever you like all that
those stats and then we just let you
play around and try to approach the
mission that way you want to approach it
the idea is the user imagination your
wits your own unique play style and all
of the different skills and gear element
that you actually get in the game to do
it your own unique way but the important
thing is is this mission area is sealed
off yeah contextually because if
something happened in the game and then
the idea is find your own unique way of
infiltrating it and then accomplishing
the mission so it's it's as open-ended
as you want it to do right are you guys
doing anything to discourage just
outright mayhem and chaos just me
charging in with a sword and a gun and
just taking on an enemy that way is it
like do you kind of want people to be a
little more stealthy and kind of take
the time we want that because it makes
more sense right but you can still try
them conical approach right you can you
can just try charging the guards but
what you'll find is that our combat is a
lot more challenging so it isn't you
know where our guards before waited
their turn to strike they don't do that
anymore they actually try to coordinate
so the more guards they are like if
there's three guards the third one I'll
just draw a gun and try to shoot you so
the idea is that not only do you have to
take care of like cards individually but
you have to make sure to dance between
them to actually destabilize them so
they don't coordinate so you can always
see you can try to do that and some
people that are really good at fight
might actually be able to pull it off
one thing we've done though is we've
given you the tools to be able to break
that cycle hide you know reset the stuff
loop
certain elements we had to change for
that first of all you know we have smoke
pumps real smoke bombs like like not you
know people coffees are like it fills
the space with smoke right and it breaks
line of sight you have other bombs that
are sort of like flash bands like very
bright magnesium bumps and it also
allows you to sort of escape there's
still the ingredients like haystacks
hide spots stuff like that but
fundamentally we changed the way guards
see you now the way that guards see they
actually have a last-known position and
you'll actually see a visual element but
the idea of making it more readable more
predictable actually allows you to plan
and you can even manipulate guards with
last-known position you know head them
into a trap for example yeah so it's
it's really a combination of many things
even the way that the HUD works the way
that you are you are seeing that guards
are detected they used to be NPC centric
so there was this triangle over NPCs
heads and you saw them in triangles
filling up right and you know he's
affecting you as a technical he's
detected you what we did now is for all
guards that are behind you there's sort
of a ring around the character and it
shows you that feedback elements on the
HUD the difference is that now you can't
get surprised a lot of times you thought
you were being really sneaky you get
detected because you didn't see the
guards that were behind you yeah so by
giving you the combination of all these
different elements really made stealth
brand-new and may see you in the earlier
games you would sneak up on a target you
would assassinate him triggers the
conversation mission over but here like
it's hard it's harder to just jump from
the rafters kill a guy and expect it to
be all over right exactly the mission is
over when you've actually left the area
so every single assassination mission we
wanted to make sure you could complete
it's tough food which wasn't always the
case before certain missions we tried to
do it but certain missions you just
couldn't it was just impossible you just
needed to run away from conflict right
this time you can actually do it
stealthily you can you can vanish
without anybody ever knowing that you're
there except for the dead guy it was
really important for us to change that
because we felt that you know it isn't
over like that the assassination isn't
that you're supposed to be an assassin
are you supposed to vanish at the thin
air you're the blade in the crowd we
wanted you to be able to play like that
speaking in a crowd how do the crowd
dynamics affect these types of black box
missions black box missions because it
seems like blending into the crowd may
be inciting a riot or something like
that seems like there's a lot of
opportunities there you know all our
missions are more open-ended right
they're all more flexible and whether
it's a black box mission or any other
mission of the crowd and the city plays
an intricate part
traditionally an AC we you know most
often turned off the
sandbox during missions because we
didn't want it to screw up the actual
you know mission steps this time we
actually embrace it we want there to be
chaos we want you to be able to like
start a fight and have ten people in the
actual crowd take up arms and fight and
protect you because you're being
attacked by these extremists right we
want that stuff to happen we want your
experience your playthrough to be unique
so it seems like one of the ways where
it actually can be really different is
depending on how you build up your
character like how can missions like
these the effect vary depending on done
when we started experimenting with coop
with with our shared experience what we
realized was that to make the experience
cool when you're playing together with
friends is that if you complementary to
be able to do that we had to have you
know people be different we had this I
mean you know we have this since a situ
right you can customize Ezio you get all
these different costumes all these
weapons the thing is that before they
used to be purely aesthetic right now
every gear element actually has an
impact on gameplay the hood might make
you you know blend faster into a crowd
the boots will make you fall from a
greater height without you know harming
the character so all of this different
these different elements will will start
making each character sort of unique
right